[موسيقى]
حقيقه انا احب ان اوضح واحد من الازمات
الفكريه في عالمنا العربي هذه الازمات
التي نجدها تظهر في الخطاب الثقافي
والاجتماعي في احوال المجتمعاتنا العربيه
هذه هي الطريقه السلبيه في التعاطي مع
احداث التاريخ وحضور السجال الطائفي
والعقائدي والديني في كثير من جوانب
حياتنا يعني تجد ان لما تاتي فكره جديده
نظريه جديده علوم حديثه بدلا من ان نتناقش
في لب الموضوع نجد ان السجال ديني او
عقائدي او حتى طائفي ياخذنا الى زاويه
بعيده جدا عن هذا الموضوع ثم ندخل في حوار
عقيم بلا سمره وبلا فائده بل قد يزيد
الفرقه والشقاق ونبتعد عن الموضوع ذو
الفائده
[موسيقى]
مع الاسف الشديد في عالمنا العربي التاريخ
بدلا من ان يكون مصدرا للثراء والجمال
والابداع واستلهام القصاص والعبر وانتاج
الاعمال الدراميه والروايات الادبيه اصبح
حلبه للصراع حلبه للشقاق حلب اهل الشد
والجذب تستدعى شخصيات من الماضي افضت الى
بارئها قبل 1400 سنه ثم نتصارع حولها
لماذا هذا لن يساعدنا ابدا في فهم احداث
التاريخ بل قد يسبب في انفصالنا عن
تاريخنا هذا تراثنا هذا جزء من حضارتنا
جزء من هويتنا هذا الشقاق والسجال لن
يفيدنا الا في انفصالنا عن تاريخنا ويساهم
في تشويه وان يكون تاريخنا ملبد بطبقات من
غيوم الصراع الديني والطائفي
[موسيقى]